[Music]
with the arrival of the summer travel
season this weekend millions of people
will need rides to and from the airport
and lyft's new CEO David richer hopes to
capitalize on that simple fact he's a
tech industry veteran and he is hoping
to rebuild the struggling ride share
company is struggling the right World
we're we'll talk about that here are
some details though lift stock is down
nearly 90 since the company went public
in 2019 and it cut more than a thousand
jobs in April now Lyft is out with a
first of its kind feature at select U.S
airports how it works is this customers
can pre-order their ride as soon as
their plane touches the tarmac the app
will then match Riders and drivers for
the best pickup time taking into account
everything from walking through the
airport and baggage claim and David
richer joins us now David thank you for
being here good morning uh would you
object to the word struggling uh and
will this feature change things uh you
know what I'm gonna go with a different
word we're going to call it uh comeback
okay how about we go with come yeah yeah
so look Lyft has been around for 16
years now we defined the industry all of
the sort of peer-to-peer you know a
friend picks you up in his car that was
the early days of lift um but now it's
time for us to sort of make our name
again and as you say we just launched
this new travel feature just in time for
Memorial Day
um and you described it super well Tony
it's like from the time the plane
touches down we will do the math to
figure out how to get you the car right
as you get to the curb is that a matter
of of updated Tech where you're going to
be better than other competitors are
predicting that travel time through the
airport that's part of it I mean look so
any great service starts with what does
the customer want and in this case the
customer wants to get out of the airport
I mean I don't know about you but like
the sort of standing oh I like staying
there do you like that is that kind of
your go-to kind of that I'll just go
hang out here well no and it's just so
funny you said you watch people the
baggage claim and they're like stressed
about the baggages my bag going to get
off all their all they want to do is get
out so we try to make it so that with
our technology and our product and
service by the time you get to that curb
you're walking off the off the property
or driving off so one of the things I
found really interesting Tony mentioned
the stock price uh down 90 since the IPO
but 77 of the stock at Lyft is owned by
institutional investors which means that
they kind of have a large sway as to
what happens with the stock price if
they love it and there's upside
potential that's great if it's if it's
headed downwards they sell and that can
be detrimental to the company so what do
you say to retail shareholders that are
holding the stock well look I just met
with a bunch of shareholders including
some of our largest last week they're
rooting for us they're rooting for us
because they're saying look this is a
breath of fresh air the Rideshare
industry I think has been a little bit I
want to say stale a little bit for a
while you know but how with products
like wait and Save which we pioneered
this is a way for you to save some money
if you want to you know save a little
bit of money and take a little bit more
time for your ride products like this
new touchdown that allows you to sort of
walk out or even integration with your
phone so that you don't have I don't
know about you I have the same same
couple of arguments with my wife all the
time all the time and one of them
involves when should we get to the
airport right are you familiar with that
one yeah so I'm a little bit of a
last-minute guy anyway Lyft will
literally give me a notification saying
now's a good time to leave we'll order
your lift for you and it'll get you to
the airport so I think that's what
really drives the the price over time
some of us were talking before the show
and I feel like with Rideshare it's
similar to other things you use what
you're used to using it's the one I
always use it's the one I always use and
you only try something else if you're
frustrated maybe how do you get somebody
who's loyal to one of the other
companies to switch is this enough or is
there another way to get some of that
other share in the marketplace I think
it's such a good such a good question
and you're right people do what they're
used to but here would be my argument my
argument is you actually want two apps
on your phone you really do and I don't
mind calling them I think you're talking
about Uber is that the company I'm
trying to yeah I've heard of those guys
so here's my thought look if every
single person has Uber and Lyft on their
phone Riders and drivers it's actually
better for everyone because sometimes
one of them is going to mess you up I
hope it's never me but at the end of the
day you want both and I think if we get
both then people are going to start to
to use us more because people like Lyft
you recently said that you are quote
open to offers when it comes to selling
Lyft why put that out there
um you have to I mean if your your
public company CEO you always have to
acknowledge that you know if the phone
rings you've got to answer it's your
responsibility to shareholders but it's
not our focus our focus is building
great products for Riders and for
drivers and I want to actually say that
again for Riders and for drivers they
both really matter to Lyft David you
were the 37th employee at Amazon I think
that's incredible what was that like and
are you invited to the wedding
my invitation hasn't arrived yet okay so
I don't know the answer to that put it
out there in the universe but I
appreciate that and Jeff if you're if
you're listening uh happy to show up
when you want me so it was amazing it
was amazing I mean this was a tiny
little 15 million dollar internet
bookstore and um look I've been a book
guy all my life I love reading I love
technology the idea of being able to put
those together and have millions of
people be able to buy books at the click
of a button was amazing and then my job
was to start the music store the video
store the toy store the tool store
really build it into the everything
store it was a great great challenge I
said the reason that I shop as much as I
do I think
because you're a CEO uh because we got
this debt ceiling negotiation crisis
really in Washington uh any advice to
our dear leaders there in DC and getting
this done and what the impact could be
to companies like you all the gig
workers who work for you Etc yeah I mean
of course my advice like everyone else
is get it done right but honestly I
think it's it's political theater you
kind of know where it's going to end up
my real view is if you want to go to the
theater I want you in a lift go out with
some friends go with some family go to
the theater yourself and have fun there
don't put your energy towards Washington
DC yeah that'd be my advice all right
David Richard David thank you very much
appreciate being here that was super fun
thanks you guys for having me take a
lift this summer